the other thing that is happening that
broke is that Donald Trump a deposition
a video of his deposition where he
pleaded the Fifth Amendment
over
400 times was released
and it is something that was reported on
that he pled the fifth a whole bunch of
times but when you see it and you see a
an ex-president of the United States of
America someone who again this is a turn
of phrase I use all the time Who Rose
his right hand and and swore a solemn
Oath a vow supposed to be a man of Honor
to to to support and defend the
Constitution against all enemies foreign
and domestic and to to Faithfully
execute the duties the president of the
United States He gave His word he would
do that
this this person who also on the
campaign Trail and over the years has
maligned people who chose to assert
their Fifth Amendment right under the
Constitution of the United States
to against self-incrimination
here's that first let's give you a
reminder of Donald Trump's very very
settled attitude about people who plead
the Fifth
when you have your staff taking the
Fifth Amendment taking the fifth
so they're not prosecuted when you have
the man that set up the illegal server
taking the fifth
I think it's disgraceful Fifth Amendment
Bob the mob takes the fifth if you're
innocent why are you taking the Fifth
Amendment Fifth Amendment
horrible horrible he pleaded the fifth
and that was the end we never heard
about him again this is like Watergate
only it's worse because here our foreign
enemies were in a position to hack our
most sensitive National Security secrets
there is nothing sacred for Donald Trump
nothing because that same man in August
of this past year sat with a deposition
with lawyers asking him questions
just days after his home Mar-A-Lago was
raided by the FBI in the Department of
Justice for the documents that
endangered our national security
and when asked questions he wrote he
read a statement
and then they asked him a question he
read another statement and asserted his
Fifth Amendment right under the
Constitution so apparently it's like the
mob it's if you're innocent why are you
pleading the fifth just using his words
against him except he did it over 400
times now obviously I'm not going to
play a clip here of him doing it 400
times but I'm gonna give you the flavor
of how this deposition went down where
he just kept referring to the statement
over and over and over watch this
uh Mr Trump I understand you have a
statement that you wanted to read into
the record yes
um would you please feel free to start
thank you very much
this is the greatest Witch Hunt
in the history of our country
there has never been another president
or perhaps even another politician
who has been persecuted harassed and in
every other way unfairly treated like
President Donald J Trump
what Leticia James has tried to do
the last
number of years is a disgrace to the
legal system
an affront to the New York State
taxpayers and a violation of the solemn
rights and protections afforded by the
United States
Constitution
she developed
I once asked
if you're innocent
why are you taking the Fifth Amendment I
was
asking that question
now I know the answer to that question
when your family your company and all
the people in your orbit have become the
targets of an unfounded politically
motivated Witch Hunt supported by
lawyers prosecutors and even the fake
news media
you really have no choice
we cannot permit a renegade and out of
control prosecutor to use this
investigation as a means of advancing
her political career
New York deserves better in this country
deserves better
this is a vindictive and self-serving
fishing Expedition the likes of which
this country has perhaps never seen
before
if there was any question in my mind
the rate on my home
two days ago Mar-A-Lago Palm Beach
Florida
by the FBI
just two days prior to this deposition
think of it wiped out any of that
uncertainty I have absolutely no choice
because the current Administration
and many prosecutors in this country
have lost all moral and ethical bounds
of decency
anyone in my position not taking the
Fifth Amendment would be a fool an
absolute fool
one statement or answer that is
ever so slightly off just ever so
slightly by accident by mistake
such as it was a
sunny beautiful day when actually it was
slightly overcast
would be met by law enforcement at a
level seldom seen in this country
because I've experienced it
the United States Constitution
exists for this very
purpose and I will utilize it to the
fullest extent and defend myself against
this malicious attack
by this Administration
this Attorney General's office and all
other attacks on my family
my business
and our country
accordingly under the advice of my
Council and for all of the above reasons
I respectfully declined to answer the
questions under the rights and
privileges afforded to every citizen
under the United States Constitution
this will be my answer to any further
questions
Mr Trump I take it you are are not going
to answer any questions about your
preparation today with your council is
that correct
when
should I say this or should I respond to
that
for all of the reasons provided in my
answer which is Incorporated herein in
its entirety
I declined to answer the question
uh Mr Trump the focus of our
investigation and what we are primarily
going to cover today involves the
presentation of your statements of
financial condition between 2011 and the
present I take it you're generally
familiar with those statements is that
correct for all of the reasons provided
in my answer which is incorporated
herein
in its entirety I declined to answer the
question
one
oh mopey What a Sad Sack Donald Trump is
there X
of America remember when he stood on the
balcony and gasped for breath desperate
to look like a strong man what happened
to that guy
I'm sad you're asking me questions I'm a
plead the Fifth
there's several things there that I want
to talk about though that the
constitution
exists for this exact reason that if I
say it's sunny outside when it was
actually cloudy law enforcement's going
to show up the likes of which we've
never seen
it's to call it hyperbole isn't doing
Justice to hyperbole
that
um now I know he says I was just asking
that question why would someone uh take
the Fifth Amendment when they weren't
guilty if they were not guilty now I
know the answer to that question he
wasn't asking a rhetorical question he
was making a statement it was
declaratory oh if you do this it's like
the mob only guilty people take the
fifth he said
and then I want to remind you and the
audience dear listener dear viewer that
taking the Fifth Amendment it is a right
under the Constitution of the United
States against uh being forced to
self-incriminate it's not I don't want
to testify therefore I'm going to take
the Fifth Amendment it's not I'm tired
today therefore I'm pleading the Fifth
Amendment that's not what it exists for
it exists if you committed a crime you
cannot be compelled to testify against
yourself
so by him taking the fifth 400 times in
this case it means he believes
reasonably believes he could
self-incriminate by answering the
questions
retelling very telling
I know a lot of people out there this is
never going to go anywhere this is never
going to be any consequence I
am not so quick on that answer I think
that there's a very good chance that he
is going to face consequences maybe not
as quickly as we would like but I
believe it could happen
I'd love to have you connect with me
again I am at Dollar Moore on on the
social medias and I'm right here on
YouTube Jesse dollar more
you may remember that a few years ago uh
the show got hacked and many thousands
of dollars were stolen we never got it
back it's a terrible feeling it can
happen to anyone but a couple of years
ago we got Aura which really gives us
significantly more peace of mind and our
sponsor Aura is the app that protects
you from scammers by alerting you
anytime your info like email passwords
social security number are found in data
breaches or also automatically requests
removal of your info from search engines
and it can reduce spam calls Aura alerts
you quickly about suspicious credit
inquiries like if someone tries to take
a loan out in your name and or as
password manager makes it easy to keep
your account secure to begin with aura
also has parental controls for your kids
devices you can restrict apps or manage
screen time set Focus time make sure
they're doing homework instead of
binging on YouTube you can try Aura free
for 14 days at aura.com Pacman use the
free trial to see if your email password
are already out there you may be
surprised the link is down below